BEACH.
FOR "CBS THIS MORNING," JANET
SHAMLIAN, GALVESTON.
>>> THIS MORNING WE'RE ALSO
FOCUSING ON HOW LIFTING COVID
RESTRICTIONS AFFECTS THE JOB
MARKET.
A RECENT LINKEDIN REPORT FOUND
HIRING INCREASED 3.5% FROM MARCH
TO APRIL AND MORE THAN 69% FROM
APRIL OF LAST YEAR.
LINKEDIN CAREER EXPERT KATHERINE
FISHER JOINS US.
GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> SO ARE THERE CITIES HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES THAT ARE DOING
MORE HIRING THAN OTHERS NOW THAT
WE'RE BEGINNING TO GET BACK TO
NORMAL?
>> THERE SURE ARE.
SO AS YOU HEARD, TEXAS HAS A LOT
OF JOB OPENINGS.
AND WE'RE SEEING, YOU KNOW,
DEFINITELY CITIES LIKE BOSTON,
ST. LOUIS, NEW YORK, THEY ARE
HIRING.
AND ALSO SOME OF THOSE SMALLER
METRO AREAS -- TAMPA BAY,
RALEIGH-DURHAM, JACKSONVILLE.
THEY ARE SEEING A SPIKE.
AND THE INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
REALLY STARTING TO SEE SOME
RECOVERY SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISING
-- ENTERTAINMENT, RECREATION,
AND TRAVEL AND SOFTWARE AND I.T.
AS PEOPLE ARE WANTING TO GET
BACK OUT, THEY WANT TO GET
ENTERTAINED, THEY WANT TO TRAVEL
IS WHERE WE'RE REALLY SEEING IS-
SOME GREAT SIGNS OF RECOVERY.
>> CATHERINE, NOW THAT WE ARE
BEGINNING TO GET BACK TOGETHER,
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE OR HOW DO WE
BEST STAY CONNECTED WHILE WE'RE
STILL APART?
>> YEAH.
IN THE WORKPLACE, IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO BUILD THOSE NATURAL
CONNECTIONS.
AND AS PEOPLE ARE COMING BACK TO
THE WORKPLACE, MANY PEOPLE ARE
SAYING, HEY, CAN I WORK A
FLEXIBLE WORK ENVIRONMENT?
AND THE KEY YOU WANT TO DO IS
MAKE SURE THAT IF YOU ARE
APPLYING FOR A ROLE AND YOU'RE
ASKING TO BE FLEXIBLE, THAT THE
COMPANY YOU WORK WITH OR WANT TO
WORK FOR HAS THE TECHNOLOGY TO
DO THAT.
DO THEY HAVE STRONG VIDEO
CONFERENCING CAPABILITIES.
IT'S ON THE EMPLOYEE WHO'S GOING
TO HAVE TO FIND THOSE POINTS OF
CONNECTION.
AND THE ADVICE HERE IS TREAT IT
AS IF YOU ARE IN THE OFFICE.
SO SHOW UP TO THAT MEETING A FEW
MINUTES EARLY, EVEN IF YOU'RE ON
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE, AS PEOPLE
ARE SETTLING INTO THE -- THE
CONFERENCE ROOM SO THAT YOU CAN
HAVE THAT CHIT CHAT.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
OVERCOMMUNICATE.
MAKE SURE THAT -- BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT RUNNING INTO PEOPLE IN THE
HALLWAYS AS MUCH AS YOU USED TO,
YOU KNOW, SEND THAT TEXT
MESSAGE, GIVE PEOPLE A CALL.
YOU KNOW, I FEEL LIKE EVERYONE
IS NOW GOING BACK TO THE OLD
SCHOOL OF ACTUALLY CALLING
PEOPLE.
SO JUST FIND THOSE WAYS TO
CONNECT.
>> SO RIGHT.
I THINK CONNECTION IS SO
IMPORTANT.
SO SHOW UP EARLY.
I HAVE TO TRY THAT.
LET ME SEE HOW THAT'S GOING TO
WORK -- SHOW UP EARLY.
THIS IS THE THING, WHEN I WAS
COMING UP, YOU WERE TOLD IT'S
EITHER TO GET A JOB FROM ANOTHER
JOB, DON'T QUIT YOUR JOB UNTIL
YOU HAVE A JOB, AND NOW THEY SAY
THAT GAPS IN THE RESUME ARE NO
LONGER A PROBLEM.
HOW IS THAT -- HOW IS THAT?
I WAS TOLD THAT'S A BIG NO-NO TO
HAVE A GAP IN YOUR RESUME.
>> YES.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BENEFITS OF
COVID IS THAT STIGMA HAS GONE
AWAY.
MANY PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, HAD TO
STOP WORKING BY CHOICE OR NOT BY
CHOICE.
AND RECRUITERS TELL US THAT THEY
KIND OF EXPECT THAT MANY PEOPLE
WERE GOING TO HAVE A GAP.
BUT WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR IS
WHAT DID YOU DO DURING THAT GAP.
DID YOU, YOU KNOW, LEARN NEW
SKILLS, DID YOU GET NEW
CERTIFICATES.
I JUST SPOKE TO SOMEONE WHO WAS
IN THE EVENTS INDUSTRY.
HE AND HIS TEAM GOT FURLOUGHED.
SO HE AND HIS TEAM FIGURED OUT,
OKAY, HOW DO WE BRING EVENTS ON
LINE.
THEY HELPED SOME LOCAL
BUSINESSES, PITCHED IT BACK TO
THE AGENCY, AND THE ENTIRE TEAM
GOT REHIRED.
SO IT'S HOW YOU TAKE THAT TIME
TO BE CREATIVE AND LEARN NEW
SKILLS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
SKILLS IS REALLY WHAT MATTERS
THESE DAYS.
>> CATHERINE, YOU SAY THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE DURING THE PANDEMIC
HAVE CONSIDERED SWITCHING
CAREERS, SWITCHING JOBS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE AS YOU NOTED ARE
REENTERING THE WORK FORCE.
IF YOU'RE IN THOSE SITUATIONS,
YOU SAY IT'S IMPORTANT TO TAKE A
SKILLS INVENTORY.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN EXACTLY?
>> SO WHAT HAPPENED DURING THE
PANDEMIC IS THAT THERE WERE SOME
INDUSTRIES OBVIOUSLY THAT WERE
INCREDIBLY HARD HIT.
AND THERE WERE SOME INDUSTRIES
WHO LITERALLY COULDN'T FIND
ENOUGH EMPLOYEES.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY WERE LOOKING
THE WRONG WAY.
THEY WERE LOOKING AT EDUCATION,
THE NETWORK, ET CETERA.
THEN THEY REALIZED SKILLS-BASED
HIRING IS HOW YOU FIND THE BEST
PEOPLE BECAUSE IT'S REALLY THE
SKILLS THAT YOU NEED TO GET THE
JOB DONE.
AND SO IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A
JOB IN AN INDUSTRY THAT YOU HAVE
NO EXPERIENCE OR YOU'RE JUST
ENTERING THE JOB MARKET, YOU
WANT TO TAKE AN INVENTORY OF THE
SKILLS THAT YOU HAVE, COMPARE IT
TO THE ROLE THAT YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN, AND YOU'LL SEE
HOW MANY TRANSFERRABLE SKILLS
THERE ARE.
AND OF COURSE, THERE ARE
THOUSANDS, LITERALLY THOUSANDS
OF ONLINE COURSES YOU CAN TAKE
TO FILL THOSE SKILLS GAPS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE.
SO THIS IS GREAT NEWS BECAUSE IT
REALLY BRINGS MORE EQUIT